pour faire passer les réformes le
président obligés de prolonger la
session parlementaire
enlèvement de l'ambassadeur américain à
beyrouth
à trois jours des élections le portrait
du parti socialiste italien
les pme à fourcade si vous libérer les
prix des services nous embauchons 450
mille personnes
la transat est de tel vraiment
l'industrie de la plaisance c'est le
dossier du jour
bonsoir dès la fin de ce journal en
direct sur antenne 2 vous avez rendez
vous avec monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing et jacques chancel
au cours de cette téléscopie jacques
chancel essaiera de cerner la vraie
personnalité du président de chercher
l'homme gaillard la lourde fonction
alors tout de suite nous le rejoignons
dans le salon dans le salon d aide de
camp bonsoir une petite précision tout
d'abord la pendule de ce bureau a sonné
8 heures avec une minute d'avancé
je suis en ce moment dans le bureau le
salon très précisément défaite de caen
grande glace dorures trumeau par delà
les portes fenêtres
le parc avec un gaz eau des plus beaux
vers une table en effet nous avons
décidé de ne pas être seulement dans des
fauteuils mais autour d'une table et
deux fauteuils
je suis dans le fauteuil que j'occuperai
tout à l'heure à 20h25 en face de moi le
fauteuil du président et je voudrais
peut-être dire quelques heures des
éléments qui entretiendront cette
conversation il y aura les questions que
tout le monde se pose d'abord le thème
que nous avons choisi la charge du
pouvoir dans les clips pouvoir du
pouvoir la solitude du pouvoir la
solitude de l'homme
valéry giscard d'estaing est il seul il
y aurait également une question
importante à laquelle vous pensez tout
ce qu'elle et l'humeur en ce moment de
la majorité
l'autre question très importante y
aura-t-il bientôt remaniement
ministériel puis nous parlerons
également de la santé de la france et
nous parlerons de l'avenir des français
et de l'avenir du président de la
république il est mato huit heures plus
tôt 20h02
nous commencerons à 20h25 le président
de rejoindre à ici dans cette pièce dans
ce salon des aides de camp à 20h20 je
vous rend l'antenne à vous hélène
vidaillat tout à l'heure
c'était prévisible les députés ne
pourront prendre que de toutes petites
vacances cet été
au conseil des ministres ce matin on a
retenu le principe d'une session
extraordinaire à partir du 1er juillet
en effet il faut bien terminer le
feuilleton des plus values et aborder
aussi le débat autour du 7e plan il y
aura donc une session extraordinaire le
1er juin j'en avais dit qu'un effet à
noter qu'il était essentiel que les
projets de réforme actuellement en cours
de décision puisse être adoptée avant
l'interruption des travaux du parlement
d'où l'utilité d'une session
exceptionnelle extraordinaire dont
l'issue de l'actuelle saison
est-ce qu'on ait fait vision rumeurs
d'un remaniement ministériel produit
quand elle
chers amis ça fait deux ans qu'ils ne
cessent de répéter les institutions de
la vème république font que les
remaniements ne se dispute en conseil
des ministres qui sont proposés par le
premier ministre est décidée par le
président de la république à votre avis
c'est dans l'air le climat politique
s'est donc de nouveau alourdi
jugez-en vous-même ou hier matin le
secrétaire général de lui dr monsieur
gainey se déclare publiquement partisans
d'un remaniement ministériel chose
inouïe sous la vème république où le
mélange des genres n'était guère
apprécié jusqu'ici
hier après midi le président du groupe
parlementaire eu des airs monsieur
l'abbé l'ange lui un avertissement
nous serons vigilants je convoquerai les
députés du dr à la mi-juillet au cas où
au cas où un remaniement ministériel
serait en gestation
cette fois c'est l'elysée qu'on met sous
surveillance
ça paraît tellement énorme que messieurs
guichard est cool murville deux sages de
l'ue dr rabroué vertement leur président
de groupe
cette nuit enfin la majorité éclate sur
l'article 5 du projet de loi sur les
plus values le gouvernement est battu
cette fois c'est l'esprit même de la loi
qui est bafouée conduite par 106 députés
eu des airs une majorité relative de
député en alignant le régime des
obligations sur celui des actions
favorisant fait les spéculateurs
boursiers tout en risquant d'affoler les
petits épargnants
porteurs d'obligations seul pratiquement
les députés républicains indépendants
soutiennent massivement et désespérément
le ministre des finances
jamais sans doute la majorité ne sera
t-elle apparu aussi divisés tout cela
sous l'oeil goguenard de l'opposition
qui compte les points et sous le regard
des français que ces jeux d'un autre âge
peuvent surprendre ou indignés affaire
de tempérament et de générations quant
au président de la république visés par
ces manoeuvres
peut-être en saurons-nous tout à l'heure
ici même ce qu'il en pense
la sécheresse fait déjà des chômeurs les
quelques gouttes de pluie qui sont
tombées sur paris
cet après midi nous rassurer personne la
sécheresse maintenant touche l'industrie
la direction de l'edf conscient de la
gravité de la situation avait dès
avant-hier diminué de 5%
la tension électrique chez les
particuliers et c'est maintenant les
très gros consommateurs que sont les
industries lourdes à qui elles limitent
ses fournitures
une quinzaine d'entreprises se sont vus
privés de courant courant dont le groupe
creusot loire en particulier mais vous
allez le voir
l'edf cependant ne fait que respecter
ces contrats en coupant l'électricité
dans certaines aciéries grosses
consommatrices de courant edf ne fait
qu'appliquer les termes de ces contrats
spéciaux il concerne les cas de grève
d'accidents sur les lignes électriques
ou comme aujourd'hui de sécheresse le
but c'est d'économiser jusqu'à 1% du
total consommé en france il y a environ
15 contrats interruptible passé avec des
grosses entreprises qui sont
essentiellement des aciéries défaut
électrique d'acier et l' avantage pour
nos clients pour nous industriels
clients fait précisément qu'ils ont à
rabais sur le prix de la fourniture
d'énergie électrique
il paye donc leur cours en moins cher et
mais il savait parfaitement à quoi ils
s'attendaient
voilà ils payent le courant moins cher
mais ils sont tenus de réduire la
puissance sur demande et on distingue
deux types de réduction de puissance
soit immédiatement en cas de besoin
pressant soit
avec préavis quel est le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'était le cas de réduction
immédiate
jusque là on vous a accusé depuis hier
depuis ce matin d'avoir profité des
coupures de courant pour mettre en
chômage technique du personnel or est ce
exact
une accusation parfaitement absurde nous
sommes extrêmement gênée par ces
coupures qui résulte de nos contrats
nous avons en effet nous sortons de
grève assez longue dans nos aciéries
nous n'avons pas de stock de lingots et
nous allons avoir un gros problème pour
alimenter nos à nouveau laminoir
nous essayons d'ailleurs par tous les
moyens de nous dépanner d'une part en
poussant celle de nos installations qui
travaillent sur d'autres procédés que le
four à arc et même éventuellement
chercher des lingots à l'extérieur ces
contrats prévoient la possibilité d'une
interruption
nous les avons depuis longtemps dans le
passé nous avons été interrompus
de temps en temps quelques jours la
sécheresse qu'on rencontre cette année
est un phénomène absolument
exceptionnelle on ne peut pas toujours
prévoir le pire mais si la sécheresse
continue vous risquez d'avoir de gros
ennuis si la sécheresse continue nous
risquons des troupes et à la limite
pendant huit semaines
pourquoi justement c'est ce qui résulte
des contrats avec edf mais ça ne sont
pas lui ça ne sera pas huit semaines
consécutives et nous espérons bien en
tout cas qu'edf trouvera des solutions
même si la sécheresse continue
l'ambassadeur américain à beyrouth
monsieur francis meslois a disparu
aujourd'hui en fin de matinée alors
qu'il se rendait chez le président élu
monsieur élias sarkis
il était accompagné du conseiller
économique américain qui lui aussi a
disparu
d'après certaines informations ils
auraient été enlevés par un groupe armé
mais les palestiniens aussi bien que les
progressistes et les phalangistes
rejette toute responsabilité dans cette
affaire
les etats-unis ont accueilli la nouvelle
avec beaucoup d'inquiétude
washington prend la faire sur un ton
presque ferme est très grave
le président ford a convoqué d'urgence
son conseil personnel de sécurité l'a
demandé aux gouvernements arabes
impliqués dans la crise libanaise
intervenir au plus vite
autrement dit l'amérique en fait une
affaire d'état
si l'américain marc censi leurs émotions
mais aussi lors des petits désespère
d'aboutir à une limitation du conflit
redoute une nouvelle guerre au
moyen-orient
tous les efforts de paix de dillinger
semble compromis dans ces conditions
faut s'attendre à une grande fermeté de
washington
si par malheur d'enlèvement de
l'ambassadeur tourner au drame
sur place à à beyrouth l'aéroport
pourrait être réouvert dès vendredi
c'est un des éléments des tentes il est
vrai que depuis 48 heures les combats
ont marqué le pas et les syriens ont
levé partiellement le blocus qu'ils
imposaient depuis plus dé jeu à beyrouth
mais il n'empêche que beaucoup essayent
encore de quitter le pays par n'importe
quel moyen
sept hommes en armes près duquel je me
trouve n'est ni à mourabitoun ni à
phalangistes ni soldats syriens
c'est tout simplement la d eau crs
chargés de garder l'ambassade de france
depuis les évènements au liban
atmosphère fébrile aujourd'hui à
l'ambassade de france
car a été organisé le convoi peut-être
de la dernière chance pour permettre à
certains français qui veulent quitter le
pays de le quitter avec le maximum de
sécurité un grand drapeau bleu blanc
rouge sera en tête du convoi et
permettra peut-être aux français de
traverser aussi bien les lignes des
forces progressistes que les lignes des
forces syriennes sans encombre il n'ya
pas d'avion que j'ai peur d'être
bloquées et qu'elle est petite il
commence à faire chaud alors préfère
rentrer avec tout le monde vous espérer
revenir
oui oui le poste de mon mari est en
principe pas tenu silly bandz qu'il nous
reviendra pas nous verrons bien le 14
septembre
ainsi il commence son père s'est passé
ces derniers jours ici à beyrouth
ça commençait à devenir un peu
désagréable surtout le manque d'eau le
manque d'électricité
le manque de nourriture fraîche enfin
n'a survécu
ça qu'on n'est pas mécontent de partir
plus tôt maintenant plus tard nous avons
plus d'instruments de mesure enfin dans
un jour 2 de ce que nous pouvions faire
voyager à côté de moins un représentant
des groupes qui font la police dans
cette région de la ville et qui assurera
la protection du convoi jusqu'à la
sortie de la ville
ensuite ont pris quelques contacts à la
montagne et puis aussi non prévenus deux
audi syrienne de l'arrivée du convoi ce
qu'ils pensent je pense que tout
marchera bien
campagne électorale et sondages c'est le
visage de vittel le dernier en date
donnent 34% à l'élément à la démocratie
chrétienne et 30 2% parti communiste
alors sans présumer du vote de dimanche
il est certain que la lutte sera serrée
et surtout que ni l'un ni l'autre ne
pourront gouverner sans faire appel au
parti socialiste qui pourraient
ressemble rassemblé d'ailleurs de 12 à
15% des suffrages
encore une fois le pays s'y jouera ruled
arbitres
le parti socialiste italien vient de
créer une certaine surprise en affirmant
qu'il était prêt à former un
gouvernement après les élections un
gouvernement socialiste
comment ce parti qui n'a recueilli que
9% des voix aux dernières élections
générales prétend constituer un
gouvernement
il est vrai que les socialistes ont des
ambitions et un certain nombre
d'électeurs qui tout en étant dégoûté
par la démocratie chrétienne ont peur
des communistes ses électeurs pourraient
donc voter socialiste
à défaut de gouverner seule les
socialistes accepterait de participer à
un gouvernement comprenant et les
démocrates-chrétiens et les communistes
ce qui actuellement semble complètement
irréel et hélas la gauche dès midi alors
une folle enquête remaniée associer des
partis communistes à la majorité
gouvernementale
si cette possibilité nous est acceptée
par des manques à capter une seringue la
responsabilité lawal main situation du
fusible en italie il est
il ne va pas s'abriter de votre maman
est-ce que vous pensez que le parti
communiste italien a suffisamment évolué
et est devenu suffisamment libéral ont
joué le jeu démocratique
repas sans que la révision des communes
c'est une révision positive
naturellement une faute des autres des
autres garanties d autres problèmes
n'est pas une question des garanties de
la cie de la socialité démocratique de
la révision démocratique n'ait commencé
la question des rapports de solidarité
avec le mouvement communiste
international
ce qui est certain ce qu'après les
élections personne ne pourra gouverner
sans les socialistes
lille et démocrates chrétiens ni les
communistes voilà un rôle tout à fait en
viable et rentable
certains sondages affirment déjà que les
socialistes vont passer de 9 à 14 % des
voix ce serait une belle réussite
mais cela ne serait pas forcément une
solution à la crise italienne
car s'il est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
gouverner sans les socialistes
les socialistes peuvent très bien
empêcher tout le monde veut gouverner
italie encore deuxième enlèvement
alimentaire entre guillemets en deux
jours après un grossiste en boucherie
hier retrouvé sain et sauf par la police
est un marchand de volailles qui a été
enlevé aujourd'hui à rome pour l'instant
les hommes masqués et armés qui ont
attaqué renato benkirane ni devant chez
lui ne se sont pas manifestés la police
italienne ne sais pas qui ils sont et ce
qu'ils veulent peut-être demanderont-ils
comme pour le boucher une vente
révolutionnaire de poulet à bas prix
dans les quartiers pauvres pour libérer
leurs otages
william coleman à toulouse dans les
ateliers de concorde
aujourd'hui le secrétaire américain aux
transports qui ne veut toujours pas
voyager en concorde a reconnu quand même
ce matin au cours d'une conférence de
presse
new york a eu tort de refuser
l'atterrissage au super sony pendant six
mois si la ville veut rester le premier
port d'accès aux états unis il faudra
que les autorités change d'avis at il
dit
un grand frisson pour le président
gerald ford aujourd'hui lorsqu'il a
découvert le dernier sondage de la nbc
la télévision américaine à propos des
élections si les américains voter
aujourd'hui pour choisir leur président
entre le républicain ford et le
démocrate carter jimmy carter gagnerait
très facilement avec 52% des voix contre
37 seulement à ford
bon perdant dans les sondages seulement
gerald ford a rendu hommage à jimmy
carter il a l'esprit ouvert et un coeur
plein de compassion
enfin box hier près de new york george
foreman a battu jo phrase hier au
cinquième round l'arbitré du combat a
préféré arrêter le massacre
george foreman le plus grand des deux
ici le plus puissant et le plus rapide
aussi a très facilement dominé joe
frazier qui a d'ailleurs décidé
d'arrêter la boxe après ce match
avec cette victoire forman redevient le
prétendant numéro un au titre mondial
des poids lourds détenus actuellement
par mohamed ali
le combat en entier ce soir sur antenne
2 à partir de 22h25 au conseil des
ministres ce matin monsieur habib a
présenté son projet de programme dans le
cadre de la réforme de l'enseignement
il concerne la première année qui suit
l'école maternelle et les premières
années de collège c'était via la 6e et
la cinquième ils portent enfin sur le
contenu que doit être le savoir des
élèves en tenant compte de
l'enseignement extrascolaires et puis
dans quelle structure doit-il s'inscrire
et comment doit-on organiser le temps de
travail
il s'agit donc de mieux organiser le
travail des enfants ce qu'ils apprennent
tenir et ceux qui entrent dans un
collège
premier petit aspect la réaffirmation
des cinq heures d'éducation physique
dans l'enseignement primaire
un peu plus de sport voilà l'idée à vrai
dire pas très neuf est difficilement
applicable
un peu moins d'heures de cours
l'allègement des horaires répond à un
souhait présidentiel mais si les 27
heures hebdomadaires en primaire
demeurent les élèves de 6e et 5e auront
une semaine de 24 heures de travail au
lieu de 25 heures 30
actuellement cela pour éviter une
surcharge excessive du temps scolaire en
laissant une certaine autonomie aux
élèves mais cette attention risque bien
d'être exception les enfants qui
éprouvent quelques difficultés à suivre
l'enseignement auront droit à des heures
de soutien une aide supplémentaire de la
part des professeurs pour la plupart des
élèves c'est à dire ceux qui ne sont pas
brillants la diminution du temps de
travail est ainsi très limité
l'allègement des horaires restent
réservés aux bons élèves pour les élèves
qui n'ont pas besoin d'heures de soutien
il y aurait abaissement des obligations
d'horaires de 1h30 par semaine ce qui ne
veut pas dire que dans certains cas
d'ailleurs les professeurs ne ferait pas
venir ses élèves à l'aise renseignements
pour certaines séances de synthèse et
d'approfondissement mais ce sera
vraisemblement fait beaucoup moins
courant que les heures consacrées au
soutien avec des élèves en difficulté
selon le ministère du travail le nombre
des chômeurs a diminué sensiblement au
même mais en l'occurrence les chiffres
ne disent pas tout et si l'on tient
compte des fameuses variations
saisonnières le chômage est stationnaire
depuis le mois dernier
justement les petites et moyennes
entreprises en conclusion de leur
congrès de nice propose à monsieur
fourcade un bien étrange marché nous
sommes distel prête à créer 450 mille
emplois mais en échange à plein déni la
liberté 900 mille entreprises relevant
des services
l'effort qui est à concevoir ne
représente qu'un salarié pour deux
entreprises
donc on peut être affirmatif à l'heure
actuelle que la demande des professions
de service est bien supérieur à ses 450
mille quatre cent cinquante mille
emplois contre la liberté des prix est
ce que c'est pas du chantage il faut
être conscient que pour pouvoir donner
des emplois il faut les rémunérer et
pour les rémunérer avoir un moyen de
trouver auprès du client qui a besoin du
service
le volume correspondant aux services
dispensés et c'est en fonction de ce
chiffre que l'on peut payer le salaire
correspondant et les jeunes social est à
l'heure actuelle beaucoup de salariés
qui désireraient rentrer dans l'une des
professions de services font la
constatation immédiatement qu'on leur
offre des salaires bien inférieur à ce
que serait un modeste salaire d'une
femme de ménage qui vient travailler
dans une famille
et alors là on comprend pourquoi
certains préfèrent rester chômeurs
plutôt que d'avoir un salaire qui ne
correspond pas à la publicité à la
capacité qu'on lui demande
jean-yves terlain à son tour vient
d'abandonner dans la transat son
catamaran que l'on disait fragile n'a
pas résisté à la tempête et il attend
qu'un cargo tiennent leurs marques
si au départ les concurrents avaient eu
un vent très léger les choses ont bien
changé en moins de deux semaines
deux tempêtes successives d'une violence
extrême ont provoqué un nombre record
d'abandons et la course est devenue un
véritable calvaire pour beaucoup de
concurrents après l'abandon de
fauconniers bras cassés après les
difficultés de colas
c'est donc vers l'un l'un des grands
favoris qui disparaît de la caisse alors
au delà des problèmes humains on peut se
demander à quoi sert cette transe on
peut se demander par exemple si elle
sert au moins au développement du sport
de la voile et de la presse
eh bien ce n'est pas sûr car si
l'industrie de la plaisance a connu un
développement spectaculaire ces
dernières années elle a eu aussi
récemment beaucoup de problèmes beaucoup
de difficultés témoins l'exemple de ce
constructeur français qui était pourtant
le premier chantier européen
cet homme s'appelle michel dufaux il a
45 ans sa profession ex pdg de
l'entreprise michel dufour qui fabrique
des bateaux de l'est après deux en
difficulté ils viennent passer la main
depuis le début de juin il ne préside
plus aux destinées de son entreprise
et pourtant cette entreprise a été
pendant dix ans
l'exemple d'une réussite exceptionnelle
qu'on en juge en 64 jeune ingénieur en
mécanique
il construit avec trois ou quatre
compagnons un bateau qui l'a dessiné
lui-même le cil
le succès est immédiat dix ans après en
74 michel dufour est à la tête d'une
usine de 600 personnes
il est devenu le premier constructeur
européen de bateaux de plaisance
il exporte dans 60 pays les 74
c'est justement l'année de la crise et
le stock de bateaux commencent à
s'accumuler petit à petit sur le
chantier
parce que les clients se font plus rares
pour des bateaux qui valent cent
cinquante mille francs en moyenne
parce que la tva en italie la baisse de
la lyre celle de la livre sterling lui
font perdre ses deux principaux marchés
à l'étranger
et puis aussi peut-être parce que
l'entreprise a grandi trop vite très
vite
ce qui impliquerait si on gagne pas
rapidement de l'argent d'augmenter
effectivement sensiblement le capital
par apport extérieur que j'ai fait mais
de peut-être de façon insuffisante
on a aussi fait des erreurs de gestion
on a mal contrôlé certaines choses bâle
sui ville et la gestion de nos filiales
par exemple est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être très seul ou est ce
qu'on vous a aidé un peu au fait je
crois qu'il va chercher des
échappatoires la mort quand il ya une
difficulté c'est quand même le chef
d'entreprise qui doit qui en est
responsable
l'année dernière pour sortir de ses
difficultés michel dufour fait appel une
première fois un patron d'industrie
passionné de voile marcel bich
mais cela n'a pas suffi il a fallu
licencier faire face à des problèmes
sociaux très grave est toujours toujours
résoudre des problèmes financiers de
plus en plus insurmontable alors début
juin le baron bich a pris complètement
contre le l'entreprise et l'a nommé à sa
tête un jeune polytechnicien de 24 ans
qui erre prions il ne restait plus à
michel dufour qui possède encore 17% des
actions qu à se retirer sur la pointe
des pieds qu'on a fait au début on a
voulu prendre position rapidement parce
que je crois qu'il était important de
prendre place à ses taux avant que le
concurrent soit trop nombreux c'est un
pari qu'on a fait bon on l'a peut-être
pas gagné on l'a pas gagné moi en tout
cas
ceci dit ce qu'on a fait reste quand
même à qui je crois pas que que ce soit
un échec total c'est quand même une
blessure d'amour propre
c'est un échec personnel oh oui dans une
certaine mesure oui oui le cas de michel
dufour est exemplaire à plus d'un titre
au delà des problèmes de la croissance
est l'ami du
petites entreprises il ya aussi un
problème régional car ici à la rochelle
la plaisance n'est pas seulement le
louette la plaisance est devenu une
véritable industrie qui emploie 2000
rochelais alors quand la plus grosse
loterie de plaisance rochelais à des
difficultés ça devient le problème de
toute une vie dans cette maison dufour
s'est développé à la rochelle c'est une
société rochelaise et nous aurions aimé
qu'elle puisse rester entièrement
rochelaise mais quand on passe vraiment
au stade industriel ce n'est peut-être
pas au niveau d'une ville de province
que l'on peut rassembler les capitaux
nécessaires ni toute la matière grise
nécessaire problème très général celui
l'aménagement des territoires à
l'organisation la société française
et puis à la rochelle comme ailleurs
l'industrie de la plaisance reste encore
très fragile d'abord parce que la
fabrication des bateaux ou des voiles et
trop minutieuse pour être réalisée en
grande série
le travail relève souvent de l'artisanat
et dans ces conditions les entreprises
sont peut-être obligés de rester petit
le problème dans la plaisance et qu'on a
produit très particulier ils vendent des
gens compétents
il manque beaucoup de créativité et
c'est pas toujours compatibles avec une
rigueur de gestion
on doit retrouver dans cette entreprise
on peut concevoir l'entreprise sur et
100 personnes en voyage à condition que
l'ambiance demeure celle d'une
entreprise de dix ils cassent personnes
en vingt ans le sport de la voile a
connu un développement considérable des
entreprises comme dufour en ont
longtemps profité mais l'industrie du
loisir est toujours la première touchée
par un ralentissement de l'économie
alors le pari du baron bich qui reprend
dufour le baril de la rochelle qui
misent toujours sur la plaisance et le
pari de tous les fabricants
tout cela dépend très directement les
aléas de la conjoncture à vous lire
nous sommes une industrie de loisirs et
comme tel très sensibles aux cours et
aux ruptures à la conjoncture économique
et où
événements socio économique c'est
pourquoi à 1975 arrête et une année
difficile
la crise a été ressentie par les contres
senti très durement et dans tous les
types de bateaux non pas dans tous les
types de bateaux certains en sont
restées bien fermes sur le marché
notamment les canaux de pêche promenade
par contre le voilier de croisière a
subi un choc très marqué alors justement
on voit une entreprise comme dufour qui
construit des bateaux de croisière
racheté par une grosse entreprise vie qu
est-ce que c'est un exemple isolé ou
bien est-ce que d'autres grosses
sociétés s'intéressent aux petites
entreprises de plaisance et bien la
crise a mis en difficultés certaines
entreprises - nombreuses qu'on peut le
penser parce que certaines s'en sont
tirés mais alors évidemment dans une
telle conjoncture les groupes
industriels ou financiers recherchent
justement les achats intéressants
d'entreprise qui serait bon à reprendre
donc il y à certains groupes qui s'y
intéressent mais en nombre limité
lors de la transat on voit des grosses
sociétés qui n'ont aucun rapport avec la
plaisance qui finance des bateaux et des
concurrents alors là est-ce que ça ait
de l'industrie de plaisance et bien un
événement comme la course
transatlantique sans nul doute on en
parle et pour la plaisance est toujours
excellent de parler de bateaux mais au
niveau des retombées du marché notamment
du marché intérieur
on peut s'interroger parce que les
industriels dont vous parlez c'est
surtout un support publicitaire qui
recherchent c'est simplement leurs
publicités qu'il vous est peut-être
s'intéresse aux bateaux peut-être à
certains moments mais c'est surtout un
support publicitaire
le temps aujourd'hui il a fait un peu
plus frais de la bretagne rhin avec
quelques gouttes de pluie sur la
normandie et l'ile-de-france ailleurs la
chaleur toujours demain la tendance est
aux frais de la manche de la bretagne
aux alpes et à l'alsace quelques pluies
en montagne sur la bretagne
ailleurs même si le ciel est plus
nuageux il fera encore très chaud avec
une tendance à leur âge sur lesquels est
née avec la rédaction d'antenne 2 je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée
tout de suite après le rappel des titres
de l'actualité que nous venons développé
vous avez donc rendez vous à l'elysée
avec monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
et jacques chancel le président
d'ailleurs est déjà installée dans le
salon d aide de camp et de quelques
minutes
l'entretien va débuter
le parlement convoqué en session
extraordinaire à partir du 1er juillet
prochain
fermeté du gouvernement américain après
l'enlèvement de son ambassadeur à
beyrouth
demain à 48 heures des élections un
reportage sur le parti communiste
italien
les pme nous embauchons 450 mille
personnes si jean pierre fourcade libère
les prix des services à 22h50 dernière
édition avec bernard pradines you